[Applause]
welcome to culinary genius today five
contestants will have their skills
tested across to punishing rounds and
world-renowned chef Gordon Ramsay will
be on hand to share some wise words our
contestants have each brought their
favorite item from their home kitchen
hoping it will help their chances here
today judging is a supremely talented
chef who's worked with the best in the
business please welcome Edward Lee
[Applause]
Edouard what are you expecting from our
contestants here today all right so the
first thing we're gonna do is start out
with a fast dicing challenge the three
best performers who make it to the next
round will have the Italian Mexican and
Chinese ingredients from the pantry to
work with we're testing speed and
finesse with a kitchen knife
so let's reveal today's ingredient
contestants please lift your potions
it's peppers all right before Edward
sets the challenge let's hear from chef
Gordon Ramsay about the most colorful of
vegetables right today you get to work
with these incredible peppers now here's
a fact the average American eats around
30 of these a year whether it's in a
super salad or a pizza or even a
sandwich trust me they are incredible
and really delicious when shopping for
peppers make sure they're tall firm and
unlike me no wrinkles what would I do
I'd turn the yellow the red and the
green into the most amazing roasted
pepper soup guys good luck Thank You
Gordon
all right I want you to cut these bell
peppers three different ways we're gonna
julienne the red dice the yellow and do
a bet on of the green so the first thing
is we're going to do a julienne a
julienne really just means a very thin
slice chop the top and the bottom of the
peppers off and you're gonna have this
nice sort of flat surface on the bottom
now you take your knife and you're going
to slice off
little rectangles now square them off
okay now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
slice the peppers into thin even strips
okay that is your julienne now this is
your dice same thing
start with the julienne come across and
just evenly cut down the line I want you
to look at that every single square is
exactly the same size that's what I want
to see last but not least we're gonna do
the bets home same thing we're gonna
square it off but you want to do just a
slightly bigger cut than a julienne see
your julienne your dice and your bet on
the competition is to see who can do the
most okay
all right back to your stations let's
see what you can do contestants you have
five minutes on the clock
knives at the ready with the ballot
begin
[Music]
I don't I know I'm loved bell peppers
because of their vibrancy my salads
adding all that color how do you like to
complete for me bell peppers I love to
cook them with over an open flame list
through the skins get this gorgeous
juicy flesh underneath you can puree it
you can chop it up and put it in the
food okay well let's see how these guys
are doing oh hi there Tran how do you
usually do with this sort of thing well
you know I don't normally I'm not so
precise so what is this would you bring
from I have fond memories of my
grandfather putting a horseradish on
everything delicious fingers nice and
tight nothing on the cutting board
beautiful thank you
all right now I see got a beautiful
portrait overlooking your shoulder who
is this lovely lady that is my
great-grandmother
I bet she's so proud of unit that you
brought her into the studio how does
that help inspire you
well she's gonna give me a love for
college we're over halfway through your
time Anand
you're taking some nice care with it I
would like what you're doing but make
sure you've got four other contestants
breathing down your neck right don't go
too slow okay three different peppers
three princesses chomping how do you
feel you're gonna fare hope I do all
right
my best only of us that's what you guys
do watch those fingers of course yep
okay so who do you feel is struggling
the most well so Laura's doing really
well she's hyper focus but the problem I
see with her is that I don't know if
she's gonna get to all three peppers and
I have to judge all three same with on
on Cantor's judge too
[Music]
get it on the ward come on guys get
something on the ward
[Music]
to impress chef Edward Lee with their
knife skills but only three can make it
through to the final round so Edward it
is time to judge the bell peppers let's
do it
you got quite a bit done so I'm very
impressed with that I am going to say
these batons look quite pathetic see how
circular they are however these look
pretty good and you got a lot done and
you got all three on the plate so pretty
good thank you
listen your juliennes I'm gonna fish
through them now make sure cuz you put
the nice ones on top let's see if the
bad ones are on the bottom you know what
they look pretty good your dice is
beautiful now your batons are a
different story too big and you know
you're gonna like pieces so I think time
caught up with you yeah okay I think you
kind of probably got too focused on the
julienne forgot to do the rest
like on a guy who'll be flustered your
julienne here is a little bit thick your
dice looks pretty good you don't have a
lot of it but it's pretty good this
baton is kind of hanging on by an edge
here so not the best work you ran into
some trouble there Debbie pins you okay
you know what makes me really really mad
know is that you have the most perfect
julienned and the most perfect dice out
of everyone
you really knocked it out of the park
it's gorgeous
but it didn't get the green peppers on
there if you just put a few green
peppers on there I could judge all three
there are other people who did more than
you but not so well so I don't know I
have to make a judgment call on that
all right well whose knife skills have
helped them to secure a place in the
final let's find out the first
contestant going through to the final is
Laura the second contestant to go
through is Anand the third and final
contestant to go through to the final is
Jason
you are today's finalists sadly of
course that means that we do have to let
go
Tron and Debbie so sorry thank you so
much for your efforts today our final
valve promises to be a fierce one as our
finalists must employ all their skills
to make a feast with today's protein
which is pork loin stakes so Edward what
are you looking for from our three
finalists here please think about
presentation think about making a
beautiful plate and if you want to use
peppers that's gonna score you a few
extra points now remember you can use
your accessory from home here and you
just have two minutes in our pantry to
select your ingredients your time starts
now
what a beautiful choice of colors to
choose from in the pantry what do we
have in there today
I see some beautifully ripe peaches in
there one of my favorite vegetables okra
also we've got hard apple cider we've
got a lima beans let's look at the
pantry I've scratchings many things that
good I Wisconsin to making my mind up as
I wet just 30 seconds left on the clock
30 seconds for the pantry I'm like a
deer in headlights you know everything
that I thought I was gonna do just gone
and I just grabbed everything that I
think I should get
now you have just 25 minutes to make a
pork dish that will stand out amongst
the rest and then you can earn $1,000 if
you are the culinary genius so let the
battle begin
[Music]
I'm not picturing my face there right so
when I started tenderizing the pork it
was to get it nice and flat no a
negative thoughts toward the judges were
Edward at all so Laura explained to me
the dish that you're making so I am
making a quickly brined pork chop on
sauteed asparagus with a creamy mushroom
sauce and I pounded it to tenderize it
so it should quick cook faster and then
you can just do it in the stovetop
smart move pound away Laura pounds away
thank you good work and on it's already
smelling really great with the spices
what do you do choose from the pantry so
I've got enough stuff to do but to do
like a rub the barbecue obviously have a
lot of time what are you doing with this
so that's basically what helped me to
start cooking so you brought this
thermometer absolutely so tell me what
is your dish so it's gonna be pan-seared
pork steaks with some with the pan sauce
I have decided what the sauce is yet and
just these carrots on the side all right
you got a lot of ingredients to work
with you went into the pantry you
grabbed a lot of things what are you
working with today I'm doing a
Portuguese to help works take the
mustard garlic red pepper sauce chips on
the side what did you grab for the
pantry you got a lot going on in here
make sure we got some pretty plates
coming out make a great grandma proud
all right
great choices in the pantry today what
would you have chosen and how would you
prepare your pork chops it's a tricky
thing to cook so what I would have done
is dice that pork real small okay and do
a stir fry because remember you have
your peppers already cut from before so
all you're gonna do is throw them into a
big wok sauteed you got all your sort of
Asian greens you got ginger you got bok
choy
you got your cilantro you get some curry
powder put it on top of a beautiful
better rice you're done all right so
Anand is working on a pan seared pork
steaks the carrots they want to
caramelize there on the side doesn't
know what his sauce is gonna be yet 25
minutes goes really fast so he's got to
figure out his dish
here's what I like what Laura's doing
pounding that steak makes it really thin
makes it perfect to cook it's a really
smart move because your window of
opportunity to cook it perfect is very
slim now on to Jason with this
Portuguese styled pork chop and then
over that mustard garlic red pepper
sauce which smelled so aromatic he's got
a lot going on it's a little bit sloppy
on his station there I want to make sure
that everything comes together perfectly
oh oh what's going on here hey Jason
Turner himself pan hey Jason we're gonna
mandolin quickly Jason just cut himself
we're gonna give him some help with our
EMT here and hopefully he'll be back
because of course the the clot can't be
stopped up I'm losing time here and I'm
worried about steaks getting overcooked
worry about everything burning I'm just
hoping that there's gonna be enough time
to make it up this is the final battle
and our three cooks are very hungry for
victory as they fight to astound Edward
with their pork dishes all right and on
you got that tool that you're using your
thermometer from home so if you were to
win the title culinary genius what would
that mean to you would be great but I
tell you what I mean just being able to
be here at Scripps retro deletes itself
is a incredible honor all right Jason
I'm so glad you're back I know you are
tight on time because of the time loss
you are really bleeding through that
bandage are you feeling okay well that's
why I think this is pepper sauce so what
happened how did this injury I honestly
I wanted to do flat cut chips I saw two
of it I was not familiar with and I took
off the tip my finger doing it so yeah
what would it mean for you especially
after this injury to be able to win this
title today well I'm in the middle of
doing my masters right now and it would
make that a little bit easier how's it
coming along is it what you think what
you're hoping for yeah it's actually
very home yeah I this is one of my
husband's favorite dishes and I know
your husband's from Africa has that
influenced how you choose to cook um so
he is born and raised in Zimbabwe so I
try to learn some of the the recipes
that he grew up with and learn from his
mother a little bit also
times a-tickin I don't want it I don't
you keep cooking with good lungs here
we're down to just five minutes folks
five minutes
a nun what's going on so we just finish
out the pan sauce now are you sure you
figured out your sauce think so what is
it
it's like that no idea but I think you
have no idea
come on you got two other contestants
breathing down your neck Senor to calm
that makes me nervous come on get fired
up
Jason you getting up already
this is what I'm talking about this is
cooking all right I was worried I was
gonna have enough time to do fries I
kind of look at dinner crispy enough and
yeah I tried one compartment on the
plate this one's all right
three minutes guys three minutes when we
see your sauce okay do you use any of
these peppers yes okay all right
I listen I am just in love with Jason
this guy's bringing it he's got one hand
and he's bringing it anon looks really
calm I if I looked at him it seems like
he knows exactly what he's doing so I
hope that's for real
Laura her dish looks good she's already
plating 30 seconds I'm just hoping that
cream sauce has enough power to it has
enough bone because it's kind of a
simple dish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
culinary genius where it is time for
Edward to judge what our cooks have
created I knew I wanted to go with the
Portuguese style pork steak because it's
just very nice the mustard here come
together very well I decided to do
something that I could execute well and
has interesting flavor we'll see if
that's enough for chef Lee
I'm pretty glad I brought the
thermometer because if I had let it go a
little bit longer than might have gone
over them so I'm hoping it's it's okay
looks pretty and just I want to taste
this horseradish sauce first brining
that hooked up with a brilliant idea
really nice I'm getting that salt I'm
getting the herb now mixing it with the
horseradish sauce makes it great but
your sauce is a little bit chunky it's
almost like I wanted to see more
creaminess more of a sauce and less of a
I don't quite know what it is almost
like an onion chutney the the flavor of
everything you've got is really
beautiful it's just a textural thing
listen
presentation-wise it's gorgeous looks
like something I could eat at a
restaurant however what in the world is
this those are the star anis that I
caramelize the carrot sighs so do you
want me to eat one no so let's do this
with it yeah okay something that you put
on a plate needs to be edible all right
if you want the room and you want that
check this out take your mic see that
look at that you'd get all the flavor on
that and I can actually eat it let's get
into this now
but what did you do what was the lemon
peel there for well just to I guess a
dilute of that essential oil if you
didn't do anything to it right no just
julienned oh that lemon peel really
harsh on there really okay I'll say that
pork chop is delicious how you
caramelized it on both sides fantastic I
couldn't have done a better job myself
your sauce it's a little bit sweet but
gosh these two together if you took this
out and this ass this is gorgeous
I love the way that you actually used
the julienne and the diced peppers
you're the only one that kept the pork
chop oh and it's beautiful it's actually
glistening on the inside because all the
juices stayed in that pork chop really
good blood sweat tears your french fries
though I would've just left the mom's
plate just didn't do it you didn't have
time to crisp them properly and then by
putting it under you just have a soggy
mess but man that pork chops pretty good
thank you all right well thanks to all
three of you guys are great efforts all
around but now add work you have that
tricky task of choosing a winner I think
we need to go have a moment okay
[Music]
to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your cloches whatever you
did to that something was so complex it
was so delicious and the pork chop was
so perfectly cooked genius
thank you
[Music]
you